gibbs free energy is symbolized by g and
change in gibbs free energy is
symbolized by delta g
and the change in free energy delta g is
equal to the change in enthalpy delta h
minus the temperature in kelvin times
the change in entropy delta s
when delta g is less than zero a
chemical or physical process is favored
in the forward direction therefore we
say that the forward process is
thermodynamically favored as an example
if we look at a reaction where reactants
turn into products if delta g is less
than zero the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favored meaning the
reaction will go to the right to make
more products
textbooks will often use the word
spontaneous so when delta g is less than
zero the reaction would be spontaneous
in the forward direction
when delta g is greater than zero the
chemical or physical process is favored
in the reverse direction therefore the
forward process is not thermodynamically
favored
going back to our reaction as an example
if delta g is greater than zero that
means the reverse reaction is favored
which favors the formation of the
reactants
for this example textbooks will often
say that the reaction is non-spontaneous
in the forward direction which means the
reaction is spontaneous in the reverse
direction
and when delta g is equal to zero the
chemical or physical process is at
equilibrium
so for our chemical reaction if delta g
is equal to zero the reaction is at
equilibrium and the concentration of
reactants and products will remain
constant
when we see delta g with the superscript
knots we're talking about the change in
gibbs free energy when substances are in
their standard states
by convention the standard state of a
solid or liquid is referring to the pure
solid or the pure liquid under a
pressure of one atmosphere
the standard state of a gas is referring
to the pure gas at a pressure of one
atmosphere and the standard state of a
solution is talking about a one molar
concentration
if our substances are in the standard
state we can add a superscript to the
equation that we saw before so we could
calculate delta g naught the standard
change in free energy by getting the
standard change in enthalpy and from
that subtracting the absolute
temperature in kelvin times the standard
change in entropy
when the substances are in their
standard states delta g naught is equal
to delta g
therefore we can say that if delta g
naught is less than zero if we're
talking about a reaction the reaction is
thermodynamically favored in the forward
direction
and if delta g naught is greater than
zero we could say the reaction is not
thermodynamically favored in the forward
direction next let's calculate delta g
naught for a chemical reaction and for
our reaction let's look at the synthesis
of hydrogen fluoride gas from hydrogen
gas and fluorine gas
our goal is to calculate delta g naught
for this reaction at 25 degrees celsius
delta h naught for this reaction at 25
degrees celsius is equal to negative
537.2 kilojoules per mole of reaction
and delta s naught for this reaction at
25 degrees celsius is equal to 13.7
joules per kelvin mole of reaction the
next step is to plug everything into our
equation so to calculate delta g naught
of reaction we need to plug in delta h
naught of reaction delta s naught of
reaction and also the temperature in
kelvin so we can plug in delta h naught
of reaction into our equation so that's
negative
537.2 kilojoules per mole of reaction
next we think about the temperature the
temperature is 25 degrees celsius and we
need to convert that into kelvin so 25
plus 273 is equal to 298 kelvin next we
think about delta s naught and here we
have to be careful with units because
delta h naught was in kilojoules and
delta s naught was given to us in joules
so one approach is to convert delta s
naught into kilojoules per kelvin mole
of reaction so we could divide this
number by 1000 or we could move the
decimal place 3 to the left so 13.7
joules per kelvin mole of reaction is
equal to
0.0137 kilojoules per kelvin mole of
reaction
looking at our units kelvin will cancel
out and that gives us kilojoules per
mole of reaction so when we do the math
delta g naught for this reaction is
equal to negative 541.3
kilojoules per mole of reaction
since delta g naught for this reaction
is negative that means the forward
reaction is thermodynamically favored so
we can think about the reactants coming
together to make the products
and since we calculated delta g not the
reactants and products are in their
standard states so what our calculation
means is if we had a mixture of hydrogen
gas fluorine gas and hydrogen fluoride
gas and we're at a temperature of 25
degrees celsius and each gas had a
partial pressure of one atmosphere the
forward reaction is thermodynamically
favored which means the hydrogen gas and
fluorine gas would come together to make
more hydrogen fluoride